at its height the Valyrian freehold
ruled over half the known world
not bad for former shepherds but the
doom fell on them and sank their capital
into the sea now volantis is the ember
of old Valyria ensuring its flame does
not go out from this world as any
volunteen will tell you and Tashi say
the same about pentose Lee scenes about
lys and so on but after enough time in
the nine free cities it's hard to see
them as anything but ashes of glory
volantis is the oldest the first colony
of Valyria after the doom the volunteers
tried to rebuild the Empire under their
rule they failed not least because the
last Valyrian with dragons Aegon
Targaryen entered the war against them
now they are content to dominate only
their lower classes or so they say
Braavos is the strangest a city erected
not by the freehold but against it a
labyrinth of illusion and deceit to hide
the refugees from Valyria slave laws
after the doom the city emerged from the
shadows to become one of the greatest
banking centers in the world a man can
get anything in Braavos for a price
especially death your own if you offend
one of the swaggering swordsmen that
pollute the city or if you're very rich
or very desperate anyone else's lease is
the easiest of the three cities full of
pleasure houses catering to every taste
no matter how peculiar many men lose
themselves in Leeson are never found at
least alive when a man runs out of coin
the lysines may grant him their other
speciality on the house poison
pentose is the most ruthless the
Magisters make a great show of choosing
the prince of Pentos from the great
families and granting him the powers of
trade justice and war as long as he
checks with Anne first on the new year
to bring good fortune to Pentos this
Prince must deflower the maid of the
field and the maid of the Seas I confess
I don't know how each is chosen but what
becomes of them after serving their
purpose but if a crop should fail of the
war be lost the Magisters will slit the
prince's throat and choose another the
other free cities are known for what
they make mia has its lenses and finery
norvos its axis quo halt it's Smith's
who can reforge Valyrian steel tie Raj
its colors I'm sure laureth had
something to the world but I can't think
of it frankly the nine of them are more
alike than they would care to admit they
hire the same soldiers to fight the same
wars for the same rulers the rich be
they called Magisters but are cons or
what-have-you when a Dothraki khalasar
approaches they gift the same tribute to
avoid the same sacking for thousands of
years the disgraced of Westeros have
drained east to pool in the Free Cities
for a man of honour counts for less than
nothing unless it raises his price
better men than I have learned that what
a man sells for gold he can never buy
back he must earn it by far and blood